each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available to have RIT CIS visiting us uh
so RIT is um currently a post also been
at techon and Maryland before that um
and he's been working on um multi-party
computation both sort of theory and
practice I think and then also more
recently on uh Bitcoin and and uh
building Fair protocols on on top of
cryptocurrencies and today he's going to
talk about some of that work thank you
uh thank you for the introduction
uh right so I'm happy to be here uh
today I'm going to be talking about uh
privacy preserving uh smart contracts
uh so let's start with um you know what
are
contracts um so contracts the way I see
it these are basically should I be
worried about that
or replay lamp in 10 minutes power will
turn
off
okay I'll try to finish the talk in 10
minutes uh so uh so the way I see
contracts are basically formalization of
uh human relationships and contracts
have been around for a really long time
so on the slide you can see um uh
contracts from the suan uh civilization
dating back to like 2600 BC and this one
is from the Tang dynast dating back to
like 700 AD so they have been like all
over the place for a long time so any
guesses as to what these uh contracts
are
for from the past any
guesses
trade yeah trade of
uh what food food so during those times
uh they were actually trading slaves uh
so it's like slaves for building and
slaves for silk so it's actually slave
for silk and some food too so yeah so
you got it partly right so um well so
mankind has progressed from like 2600 BC
and you know somewhere down the line we
had phones and uh phones became smarter
right so why not why not contracts so
smart contracts uh these are actually
envisioned uh by Nick shabo in in his
1994 essay and uh the the deal with
smart contracts is they try to automate
contract management okay so in his essay
uh he talks he gives this
example it's a bit weird I don't know
where to
stand so uh he gives an example of of
this key uh which unlocks a carard if
only if the monthly installment is paid
on time so you go and buy uh a car from
a car dealer and you promise to pay him
like monthly installments and it gives
you a key an electronic key and this
unlocks the car if and only if you pay
the monthly installment you pay the
monthly installment it unlocks the cut
you don't pay it it doesn't uh it
doesn't unlock so um so with smart
contracts you know today everything is
connected to the internet right so
automating contract management is not
per se super hard right so what is what
is really smart about smart contracts is
that they're uh they're self enforcing
self enforcing in the sense that you
don't need any kind of third party
intervention so if something goes wrong
you don't have to go and sue someone and
wait in a court of law for like six
months for something to happen so so
smart contracts are smart in the sense
that they they make like self- enforcing
uh they make contract self enforcing so
let's be a bit more precise about all
the things that I'm talking about uh so
for this talk uh you have to think of
contracts as exchanges okay and
exchanges of what these are exchanges of
like uh information uh for computation
information for information information
for money computation for money you know
exchanges some exchanges involving all
of the above so these are what what I
mean by contracts and by smart contracts
I basically mean self enforcing
exchanges so exchanges where you don't
really need to rely on a third party to
set things right so what is difficult
about smart contracts you know why why
is enforcing hard at all so let's look
at a very simple example of uh of an
information to information exchange so
here uh Alice and Bob each have their
own pieces of information you could
think of as like some some kind of
confidential information maybe they are
like spies trying to exchange some
information or you can think of this as
like a bill of sale for a car and this
is a bill of sale for a land and they're
just trying to exchange some property
and they're trying to exchange some some
legal documents and uh now um what you
want at the end of the protocol is
either the exchange happen successfully
or it or it does not happen at all it
has to be like kind of atomic and uh the
way things can go wrong is well you know
someone has to start the protocol right
so maybe Alice starts the protocol sends
over a document uh but then Bob becomes
uh you know Bob is malicious and we
basically dealing with counterparty
risks right so this is this is what can
go wrong uh when you're talking about uh
you know contracts where you want to
enforce them without without any kind of
third party but exchanges happen all the
time in the real world so you know how
do people deal with these uh
counterparty risk well they actually use
uh use an scow service right so there is
some kind of a trusted Angel out there
who who doesn't take either party's side
and then you just use the angel to um to
perform the exchange right so so here in
particular uh you know if you want to
perform if you want the angel to perform
the exchange then uh in addition to the
information you also need to specify
some conditions on the information so
this says conditions that the other
person's information must satisfy so
this is this I'm going to capture by the
Greek symbol fee so the Red symbol is
actually going to check uh the red
information for validity so this could
be like you could think of the signature
containing I mean the the document
containing the correct signatures from
the correct authorities imagine it's
like some bill of sale uh of a car so it
has to be assigned document signed uh by
the DMV uh attesting to like hey this is
the car this is the model this is the
make this is the Year this is the owner
right uh so so you have these like
conditions so the right condition checks
for the red information the blue
condition checks for the blue
information then if you have an escrow
what you're going to do is well you're
going to give the escrow both the
information as well as the condition the
the escrow is going to check whether the
condition you know matches the
information and if everything is great
then it's just going to perform the
exchange right so this is this is how uh
things happen in practice this is how we
defeat uh counterparty risks in the real
world
today uh but what does this mean for
like smart contracts so smart contracts
you want like self enforcing exchanges
you don't want any third party right so
so in this solution our escrow is really
necessary so can maybe we can do
something clever not use the escrow just
use you know some kind of maybe
cryptography or something else to beat
uh to to not require an esro and just
perform the exchange between just
between Alice and Bob but here we are
faced with uh an impossible result from
the 1980s uh due to cleave uh so he
actually shows it's such exchanges are
impossible to enforce without a trusted
party so if you want an information to
information exchange then you need to
involve a trusted party that's that's
what his impossibility result shows so
where does this leave us with uh do you
have a question okay so where does this
leave us with with smart contracts you
know with smart contracts we don't want
to involve a third party uh but then
clees impossible result says that uh you
cannot enforce these exchanges without a
third party so so what's going on here
so what what am I going yeah so Fair
exchange I guess with no
conditions
by oh so gradual yeah so this this kind
of approach is called as gradual release
so you know maybe you encrypt the
information uh and then now you just
want to exchange the keys and you
exchange the keys like bit by bit so I
send you one bit of the key you send me
one bit of the key and we go so on so
forth uh the problem with that approach
is uh well what happens if um uh you
know you maybe it's you're exchanging a
128bit key and uh uh you have exchanged
up till the 70th bit and then one person
stops because he has a superc computer
in his backyard and he's able to
bruteforce the remaining uh you know 50
58 bits the other person the honest
party well so it's not clear what you do
when you know sometimes you might want
the the honest party to do an
exponential amount of work which is not
it's not reasonable uh the other
drawback is well you know for every
Exchange you have to kind of like go
back and forth 128 times as much as many
bits uh as you're trying to exchange so
there's a couple of drawbacks and on I
mean uh at the end you you you still not
be able to prove anything formally you
cannot beat this impossibility results
so yeah so that's definitely something
that you could use in practice but it
can when the abot happens after the 70th
bit you start running into problems
otherwise you otherwise your probably
works right so um yeah so so how do we
uh what happens to Smart contracts when
uh when you're faced with this Cleaves
impossibility result so we you know what
am I going to talk about so in some
sense I'm going to talk about like
bypassing CLI uh impossible result and
here we are going to be um our intuition
is going to be guided by this uh by this
picture that that I showed you before uh
so in today's world you know there is
exchange of information and money which
happens all the time you know you buy
newspapers right so so in some sense
information has some value you can put
some uh price tag on the information
right so you can equate uh information
to have some value let's look at a
different type of escrow you know not
not the the information escrow that we
saw before but but something like a
money escrow uh so we actually need to
bring like money into the picture so so
let's say the the protocol starts in the
following way so
each this was a 10-minute thing so
so so let's bypass uh C gives impossible
result again so just to give a little
bit of wait just a second to give a
little bit of context so so we were
dealing with uh difficulties in self
enforcement of like information
information exchange and there you had
to deal with uh counterparty
risks and uh the way um uh you know
people today deal with counterparty risk
is well by using an escrow service so
here you have to specify these
conditions which the other person's
information has to satisfy uh I'm just
going back through this the the slides
that I just finished before uh so the
escrow will check for the for the
conditions if everything is good then
it's going to perform the exchange so
the escrow The Trusted angel in the
middle does not take any any person's
site and and the question is well this
is not uh completely third party free
you're still using a third party so ASC
is really necessary and here we looked
at um uh The Impossible result due to
Cle which says that well these these
information to information exchanges are
impossible to enforce without a trusted
party and this is like kind of bad news
for uh for smart contracts because you
want to get rid of uh get rid of third
parties right and uh so in this talk um
I'm going to be uh uh uh looking at ways
where how we can bypass clees
impossibility result and here our
intuition is Guided by this uh by this
triangle that we saw from before um so
information to money exchanges will
happen all the time uh in the real world
so so what this means is that
information has some value we can put
like some price tag on the information
right so let's look at a different type
of escrow which is different from the
information escrow that we saw earlier
now it's a money escrow and we bring
money into the picture um and so so can
people see all the all the pictures okay
good uh so um you know so so in addition
to the uh to the information and the
conditions they're also going to deposit
some money with the escrow then they're
going to start performing The Exchange
and now if the exchange goes bad uh then
the the money escrow is going to uh
compensate uh the honest party right so
so the information exchange is still
going bad so so Bob gets both
information Alice does not get Bob's
information but Alice is compensated uh
with some money and uh well you can set
the safety deposit to equal to the value
of this information so this seems to be
like a very reasonable uh notion in
practice right so the exchange still
goes bad but but Alice get some
composition the honest party gets some
compensation uh but but why is this any
better you're still using a trust a
third party so it's not it's still not
like smart contracts right so you're
still relying on a third party so why is
this any better so here my work shows
that uh this escrow is impossible uh
it's it's possible to implement it in a
setting where you have a self- enforcing
information to money exchange right so
we can get rid of this uh trusted Angel
if you have self enforcing information
to money exchange so let me go a bit
more into what I mean by the self-
enforcing information to money exchange
so I call this as claim or refund
transactions so so you can think of like
Alice making a transaction to Bob uh and
she specifies some information some
condition uh on on the transaction and
also puts put some money right and now
Bob can claim this uh when he claims
this so he gets the money but then Alice
gets the information so it's kind of
like an atomic swap of uh information
and money uh and of course Bob could be
malicious and he does not perform this
swap in this case the money just goes
back to to Alice so if either the swap
happens or the swap does not happen Okay
so this is what I mean by a self
enforcing information to money exchange
and we want we we are going to implement
this escrow where if if the exchange of
information does not happen properly
Alice gets compensated we want to
implement this using claim or refund
transactions which which give yes does
that involve a timeout like yeah so it
does involve a timeout so Bob can claim
this until certain time if it times out
then uh uh the money just gets refunded
back to Alice right so I'm I'm talking
about like uh a claim or refund
transaction with a self enforcing
information to money exchange but it
still seems that you know how do you
enforce this thing do you maybe you
still need a trusted party to ensure
that this exchange happens automically
right so again like why is this any
better we we switch from different
escros but it's still not clear uh why
it can be made self enforcing H and the
punchline here is this is that Bitcoin
implements this information to money
exchange this self enforcing information
to money exchange this is possible to
imp Implement in Bitcoin so this claim
or ref transactions you can Implement in
Bitcoin so if you're willing to uh take
the leap of faith and assume that
Bitcoin is real money uh then Bitcoin
makes this information to money
exchanges very explicit because in
Bitcoin the money is tied to the public
key and if you have the knowledge of the
secret key then you own the money right
so in some sense if you have the
information which is the secret key then
you then you have the money right so
there some kind of an automic exchange
of information and money so if you look
at the at the blockchain which is like
the public list of transactions uh which
are collected in Bitcoin uh in this data
structure so you can see that if if uh
if Bob wants to spend the money that
Alice sent to him to Carol in in tx3
then he basically has to produce a
signature under his public key in order
to this so This the Bitcoin transactions
are already like conditional so you have
to produce the signature in order to
spend the money in the correct way so
even like basic transactions they're
already conditional you need to know the
secret key in order to produce a
signature and then you can spend the
money and Bitcoin transactions can be
even more like General in the sense that
you can you can put in like any
condition on top of this so these are
called as Bitcoin scripts you can you
can put like an additional script which
check for which checks not only for the
public key uh for the signature under
the publicy but also checks for
additional additional conditions maybe
conditions on the
information right so but but who is uh
enforcing uh these conditions you know
how how how is all this happening why
why can't Bob you know even if it
doesn't not if he does not have uh maybe
someone else could could claim this uh
money that was spent to Bob so so why is
this um not allowed in Bitcoin uh here
you know Bitcoin has it like novel
mechanism in which uh it incentivizes
Bitcoin miners to validate conditions
and maintain the blockchain so it's the
miners who are doing this checking so in
other words there's not like a single
trusted escrow which is which is
performing which is validating all these
exchanges but it's more like a network
of miners who are validating the
conditions and they're maintaining the
blockchain yeah it seems like through
Bitcoin something is happening which is
theoretically Impossible Is it is it
that is it the case so you you can think
of it like that or the other way to
think of it is like well if you have a
trusted third party right then then you
can beat all the impossibility results
because the impossibility result
basically says you need a trusted third
party you can think of Bitcoin as like a
network of trusted parties network of
parties you trust like a majority of the
computing power whatever assumptions
that Bitcoin needs uh to function and to
maintain it maintain the blockchain so
you're relying on that assumption as
opposed to just like one single point of
failure or a trusted es you're relying
on a network of on network of minor so
that is that is the way that is the way
to think about it so you can think of it
as like beating the impossibility result
I mean in some way Bitcoin is um Bitcoin
gives you like a bank system a currency
system without any central bank right so
in some sense it's beating an
possibility result there so it's kind of
in the same way it's also beating an
impossibility result here so that's one
way to think about it but uh you know so
but you might not be happy with this
equation that Bitcoin is real money
maybe American government Will Will just
ban Bitcoin tomorrow right so so what am
I talking about is the stuff that I'm
going to tell is it still going to be
relevant well the thing here is I'm
going to be designing protocols based on
this substraction of this information to
money exchange based on like claim or
refund transaction so in my protocols
I'm just going to show you this like
arrow notation and how how you set
things up so that so that you get your
information to information exchange or
like General smart contracts but this
arrow is going to hide a lot of these
like implementation details on how you
actually do it on bitcoin so in other
words uh this claim or refund
transactions uh this abstraction is
definitely Bitcoin inspired but it's but
it's Bitcoin independent so in
particular you could you could have like
this this abstraction this abstract
claim or refund transaction being
implemented by a by an information to
money escrow right is now it's be it
becomes like a single party which uh
which implements this abstraction and
this could be like something like Bank
of America or PayPal anybody that deals
with with money uh you know these these
institutions typically deal also with
information your sensitive information
so so they are like in a very good
position to to implement this
information to money escow or you could
always go and use like a blockchain
implementation you know either Bitcoin
Litecoin ethereum any of your any any of
your favorite uh all coins as long as
they implement this uh claim or trans
actions the protocols that I'm going to
show are still going to remain secure
right and the deal is we will still be
uh worrying about like privacy and
scalability issues which makes sense no
matter which implementation you work
with so uh to be I mean to give more
details uh so if you're wor if you if
you're using an information to money
escrow and you're going to use this
escrow to exchange this information then
what this means is that you're relying
on a single point of failure right so
there's going to be like this you know
Bank of America server or something
which is storing all the information and
well we know that you know servers these
days get hacked all the time right so
your information is going to leak uh so
through a data Bridge your information
is simply going to leak right in the
blockchain implementation Things become
even much worse because to in order to
check if this information satisfies this
condition you need to make the
information public anyway so this could
be like sensitive information because
the miners are the ones who are checking
this whether this information uh you
know checks out with the condition so so
the miners need to know this information
in order to check whether whether this
condition is satisfied so in the
blockchain world Things become even
worse with respect to privacy right when
you look in terms of scalability well
every time you use a claim or ref
transaction you have you're going to pay
like some kind of a transaction fee to
the to the to the information to money
cre let's say a Bank of America every
time you use it Services you're going to
pay some kind of transaction fee and
this transaction fee could depend upon
the complexity of the condition that
you're verifying right maybe this
information maybe this condition takes
like six hours to to verify the bank the
bank is not just going to do it for free
it's going to charge you uh money
proportional to the the complexity of
the verification so so in terms of
scalability you still need to work a bit
hard right uh in the blockchain world
Things become even worse because a large
a large condition or a large piece of
information uh actually is is disastrous
for the consensus mechanism in Bitcoin
so one thing is said well you need the
miners to verify all this information
with with this condition and and if the
information verification is going to
take like hours then the miners might as
as well just not perform the
verification right so so you start so
this this is a problem where you you're
kind of like trusting a network of uh
parties to carry out the verification
but they're not doing it at all right so
then this totally undermines your
contract also when you have like large
pieces of information floating around
the network then uh you know this is
going to affect the consensus mechanism
because different parts of the network
are seeing different different pieces of
the information it takes a longer time
for them to synchronize with uh you know
synchronize all the stuff in the
blockchain so no matter which
implementation you choose you still need
like privacy preserving mechanisms
because you know the naive Solutions
just just don't simply work and you also
need to minimize the onchain complexity
when it comes to like scalability right
and in this talk I'm going to show you
how to start with like these claim or
refund transactions and using a little
bit of cryptography we're going to
design SM smart contracts which are both
scalable as well as privacy preserving
so this is what I'm going to show you uh
in the rest of the talk so let's start
with this like simple information to
information exchange that we wanted to
uh to implement so this this is the
stuff the stuff on the left is what we
want to implement right so parties
perform the exchange The Exchange goes
bad then uh the honest part is getting
compensated right so this is what we
want to uh Implement you know if the
exchange doesn't go bad then you know
they exchange they exchange the
information everybody's happy if the
exchange goes bad then uh the ownest
party gets composited so this is what we
want to implement what we want to
implement this using claim or refund
transactions so this is like uh you know
the first uh thing that you would try
well Alice makes a claim of refund
transaction to Bob and Bob makes one to
Alice so they each so Alice deposits her
money and Bob deposits his money and
specifies the condition and then when
they want to exchange uh you know so so
so Bob's Bob's information satisfies
this condition he gets Alice's money and
and vice versa right so in this case
parties end up with each other's
information on coins so this is like
kind of like a fair exch nobody loses
money nobody loses any information
right so this is one way to go about
doing it but of course this is only when
both parties are are completely honest
and they're following the protocol right
uh what happens if if something like
this happens let's let let's see what
happens if uh if something goes wrong so
let's start with this case where uh
where uh Bob does not make a deposit
right so Alice makes a deposit but Bob
does not so she makes a claim of refund
transaction but Bob does not because Bob
does not make a transaction uh Bob is
obviously not losing any money so he
keeps his
money uh but then uh now Bob can go and
claim Alice's um uh money using her
claim or refund transaction and what
happens here is that uh uh the honest
party actually ends up losing money
right so Bob gets both the coins uh
Alice gets both the information but but
this is an honest party she started the
protocol you know putting some money but
then at the end of the protocol she ends
up losing money so so it's kind of like
no good this is not what we wanted on
the on the left side so we want an
honest an honest party to start the
protocol with a full guarantee that it's
not going to lose money because it's
it's behaving honestly right and we want
to like um circumvent this problem and
if you look closely the reason why there
is a problem is because uh Bob needs
just his information to satisfy the
condition for alysis uh claim or refund
transaction so we have to kind of change
that we don't want just Bob's
information to to to let him get alysis
money and the main idea here is well to
use uh to use a double lock so basically
uh Alice makes her claim a refund
transaction puts her deposit but then
she specifies that Bob has to supply
information that satisfies both the red
condition and the blue
condition so Bob has the red information
so he can satisfy the red condition but
he does not have the blue information
right so he cannot he cannot directly
take it so let's look uh let's run
through uh an honest execution of the
protocol so how is this supposed to work
well first uh Alice is going to claim
Bob's transaction right so she satisfies
uh the blue condition releases the blue
information gets gets the money now Bob
has both the red information and the
blue information so he can he can go and
uh any
questions first
Horder yeah so this one is claimed first
and after that so so yeah so the
deposits are made this one is made first
then this one is made then this one is
claimed and then this one is uh also
claimed right so what effectively has
happened is that parties end up with
each other's information information as
well as
coins so now so this is of course again
it's an honest execution let's look at
what happens when uh let's say Bob
cheats and uh the same attack as before
let's say Bob does not make a deposit uh
then again Bob is not going to lose any
money I mean he's actually not making a
deposit so he gets to keep his money but
then now he's not able to claim the top
transaction because he does not have
alysis information Alice's information
would have been revealed only if she had
claimed this she does not claim it so
soob does not have uh have uh have all
the information to uh to satisfy the top
conditions so so that thing just gets
refunded after the timeout right so so
so what has happened here is that uh
Alice Alice does not lose money they
don't they don't exchange the
information information either but this
is like an automic swap just that the
exchange never happen it's not an unfair
exchange so we happy with this as if
like one party just never started the
protocol right so let's run through like
uh one other cheating scenario where uh
where Bob Chase but this time uh he does
not claim the transaction last time he
did not deposit now he makes a deposit
but he does not claim right so here
Alice Alice again makes uh claims Bob's
transaction gets Bob's money and now Bob
does not claim uh Bob has both the
information so he's just happy with it
no he's not going to claim the top
transaction so what happens here is that
after the timeout uh Alice is going to
get that money back and uh effectively
what has happened here is that Bob has
lost his deposit right so Alice gets
both uh both the money both the coins
Bob gets both the information but this
is okay because this is exactly what we
saw what what is happening here in the
left right so so this is I've just run
through only only the examples where
like Bob is corrupt but this also works
equally well when Alice is corrupt uh
but so it looks like we have we have
implemented this information to
information exchange using just claim or
ref transactions but the problem here is
that there's kind of like no privacy
here right because uh when you're
exchanging the claimer refund
transactions are actually checking this
information and this information is
going public on the blockchain for the
whole world to see okay so so this is
not good so we solve the problem kind of
like the exchange problem we solve but
the Privacy problem Still
Remains and uh well how do you solve a
privacy problem you know you're going to
use some kind of encryption right so
you're going to encrypt uh the documents
and maybe exchange the encrypted
documents but once you encrypting how do
you check under the encryption right so
you need more than encryption and I'm
going to say that we need uh we need
something like privacy preserving
computations so in the in the very
general case uh you can think of this as
uh Alice having some input X and Bob
having some input Y and they want to
they want to compute some function f of
XY on their inputs but without revealing
any extra information about their inputs
so you can think of this as like Alice
has their information Bob has this
information they want to check if uh if
the information is valid and maybe
possibly encrypt it and do other things
but they want to do this in a way such
that this this computation itself does
not should not leak their information
right
away and uh so how do we get get to do
this let's let's start with the mental
experiment where uh well let's say they
have access to an angel then things are
very simple right you just you just
submit your inputs the angel computes
the output and gives you back the result
so you know what what what Alice and Bob
get at the end of the interaction is
basically just their outputs so so in
some sense this gives you the best
possible privacy right so this is the
best that you can hope for uh Alice and
Bob they just just get the output of the
computation they don't get anything else
right uh so so can we implement this
right so that is that is the thing but
but here we are we are faced with with
the impossible result due to Cle which
says that these types of angels they're
not possible to implement even for like
simple exchanges you just want to
exchange you know they start with x y
and you just want to swap uh x with Y
it's it's not possible so that's what
CES impossible result say right so well
maybe we cannot do this maybe C's
impossible result has to do with like
the fairness and maybe if you relax fa
my things might be okay so let's look at
a different type of Angel where this
Angel is now going to give the output
only to only to Bob okay let's in the
general case it's only going to give the
output to the corrup party and then the
C corrup party can decide whether it's
whether the angel should deliver the
output of Alice but it can decide maybe
it should not deliver the output Alice
so it's up to the car party right so the
car party can say deliver the output to
Alice or not so you still get the best
possible privacy because what what
people get at the end of the interaction
is basically only the output they don't
get any extra information about the
other person's uh input like Alice does
not learn anything more about why then
than just like the final output and same
thing with uh with Bob as well uh so you
still have best possible privacy but you
don't have uh but you don't have
fairness and this uh maybe like many of
you in the audience already know this is
basically the big result from the 1980s
this is secure computation right so you
can Implement Angels via cryptography
and you know this you can do and and the
parties are malicious so on and so forth
gives you the best possible privacy but
no
fairness so so armed with this tool so
let's look at how to make uh the
information information exchange that we
saw before how do we make it private so
well actually so this is what it means
implementing the angel so you throw the
angel out and then just replace it with
a protocol so let's look at uh let's
look at private fire exchange so earlier
we saw that U you know to do this
exchange U these these conditions
checking this information publicly on
the blockchain and this was this was bad
now we are going to use secure computer
uh to make things better and uh so
obviously they're going to Alice and Bob
are going to engage in a secure
computation protocol so let's specify
what what is the function that they're
trying to compute as we said before it's
going to involve some kind of an
encryption because you don't want to you
don't want to release the information
out publicly right so what the secure
competition is going to do is going to
generate some fresh onetime encryption
keys so fresh encryption Keys generated
inside the secure computation protocol
then uh the secure computation uh
protocol is going to check whe whether
you know this this information satisfies
this condition this information
satisfies this Condition it's going to
perform all the checking inside the
secure computation without revealing the
information and then it's going to
encrypt uh encrypt this information
using the using the onetime encryption
Keys then it's going to give out some
output right uh not that how the output
is gener how what what output is
delivered to the party so Bob basically
gets alysis information but it's
encrypted under Alice's key and Alice
has that key Bob does not have that key
right Bob has the red key uh but he does
not have the blue key and he has the has
alysis information encrypted with the
blue
key now know that secure computation
does not give you fairness so it's
possible that only only Bob got this
output Alice did not get this but but
you can see that you know this just
these two does not give any information
to Bob because he he only has Alice's
encrypted information he does not know
how to
decrypt right so now what we need to do
is basically exchange the case this is
kind of similar to the gradual release
where you exchanging bit by bit now we
want to exchange the case but again you
have this problem right so if if Alice
sends over a key then that's that's not
good because then you know we're running
to the same problem as before but this
is basically some kind of an exchange
like this this is what we have to do but
here in this in this picture we had
these conditions fee which we're
checking for the information so we kind
of we we kind of need to have some some
conditions to check the keys that's what
we need right then you can then you are
then you in the same they in good shape
it's the same problem as before but how
do you generate this uh this condition
which which checks the keys well you can
also do that inside the secur
competition protocol right so you you
generate some authentication information
for the keys so this will be the the red
FK which checks for the red key the blue
FK checks for the blue key and now you
can also give this to the parties now
you know you have set all the things up
you know they have to exchange the keys
they know the conditions the same as
before they were exchanging some
information they know the conditions
keys are some information right so you
can just use the protocol from before
using claim or refund transactions and
you can perform this exchange again with
a guarantee that if the exchange goes
bad then the other person get get some
compensation right so this is kind of a
little bit weird because uh usually the
encrypted information is is what goes
out publicly and then the keys are kept
private right but here the encrypted
information is what is kept local and
the keys go public but these are like
one time one time keys so this is
totally fine right so you still you
still get privacy right the encrypted
information is is kep local the keys are
going public this is kind of reverse
from what happens usually but you still
get
privacy so one of the
is yeah so so that that is you know at
that level you cannot you cannot
guarantee anything right so even in this
exchange after the exchange they can
always release release the release the
information okay right so we are not
worried about that that that aspect of
privacy what we want is if if if the
honest party wants some you know maybe
maybe both parties care about privacy
right maybe both of them are honest and
they're just worrying a little bit that
maybe the other person is going to cheat
during the exchange and they want to use
Bitcoin but then if you use this
protocol then all their information is
going to go public on the blockchain
right whereas if you use this then they
they they get to keep their uh you know
information local only the keys go
public and then if they are like super
malicious and they want to like release
the the information public then uh you
know they could always do
that yeah that's not something we
prevent but uh but anyway so yeah so the
encrypted information is kept local the
keys go public but it still gives you
privacy actually we hit like two birds
in one stone we also get like
scalability because instead of
exchanging these like huge uh pieces of
information on the blockchain we are
only exchanging 128bit
keys right so this also gives you uh so
secure competition not only gives you
privacy but also gives you scalability
here what about the two new conditions
that you have generated those are simple
conditions yeah so you can think of this
as so a 128bit keys the the condition is
just like a hash on the keys so so so
this key is legit if uh you know so this
this condition FK red FK will contain
the hash of the red key and you know if
if Bob change this key to a key Prime
then it will not uh satisfy the hash at
that level that that is the level of
condition checking that you want so
again that's a good point so so here the
Ino the condition was checking some
information if this information was
large and the condition was large it's
like terrible but here you're basically
checking only uh cash of a 128bit key
which is totally reasonable this is
something that's supported in Bitcoin
today so secure computation gives you
both privacy as well as as well as
scalability in this uh for for
information information
exchange so let's uh so so so far we saw
this like information information
exchange let's let's look at something
which is more General right so here I'm
going to use this uh use poker as an
example and uh poker turns out to be a
pretty good example because it involves
a mix of everything like some
information computation money exchanges
of everything players start with uh with
their secret cards which is like some
kind of secret information then they
have their own player strategies they're
going to do some computation uh
according to the game and then at the
end of the game well someone is going to
well they're playing the game so that
one of them wins right so there is some
money automatically involved right so uh
so poker is a very good example of a
general contract and maybe maybe you
don't care about poker I don't care
about poker poker is a billion dollar
industry and uh you know Insider attacks
happen all the time and there are some
times casinos just like run away with
all the money all the players deposit
these all all kinds of things happen in
poco case and if you have a self-
enforcing contract for Poco that would
be like pretty cool right so but here
this this is like U uh more difficult
than than just the pl information
information exchange that we saw before
in at least like three three different
respects so so the first thing is that
well a poker game consists of like
multiple moves not like one swap of
information information but it's
multiple swaps you know multiple rounds
of betting
and cards revealing and so on and so
forth and we need to penalize aborts
after every maybe the maybe the player
aborts right after after the first thing
when he sees his cards and he doesn't
like it it's just ating you still have
to you know compensate the honest party
right because it's an unfair
game and the second thing is well who
deals the Cs because you don't have any
trusted party we want to get like a
self- enforcing contract for poker and
you canot just let any party deal the
cards because you know well it will deal
the best cards for itself right and the
third thing is uh we still need to add
payout to the winners this is something
that was not there in the information
information exchange but here we want
the winners to to get the payout or or
at least get the compensation if the
other person it somewhere in the
middle right so let's look at uh so
let's let's start with like multiple
moves uh how how to design multiple move
contracts so let's set uh some things up
for in terms of like notation so so here
Alice and Bob want want to play like a
multiple move game okay they are
basically exchanging multiple messages
so you know Alice sends M1 Bob sends M2
and so on and so forth and the key thing
here is that Mi might depend upon the
previous things so think about this as a
poker game your move depends upon the
previous moves in the game it's not
something that you knew up front it's
something that that uh that you generate
depending on how the how the game
proceeds and then you can have uh you
know each of these uh each of these
messages or moves you can you can think
of it as satisfying some kind of
condition because the these are these
are conditions which enforce that the
game is played according to the rules of
Poker or something like that right so
let's look at how how we would Design
This multiple Mo exchange and this is
how the The Exchange looks so so the
deposits are made one by one and you
have these conditions so the conditions
F4 basically checks for all four
messages F3 checks you can think of this
like extension of the double lock so
there you had F1 which which just checks
alysis message F2 checks both alysis and
Bob's first messages and then this
checks uh you know uh Alice Bob Alice so
three it checks three messages and so on
and so forth you can also see that uh uh
the amount of money varies a little bit
right so for the first move is just one
one Bitcoin for the second move is two
and third move two and so on two two two
two two until like the end which which
is just one Bitcoin so let's just go
through like uh an honest execution how
how you know people would play like a
multiple move game uh so the deposits
are made uh from the top and but the
claims will be made in Reverse so this
is how the claims will will happen so
first you know so Alice claims M1 then
using M1 you know Bob can generate M2
and claim claim her money and so on and
so forth so you can see that at the end
of the game uh you know Alice gets uh
three coins from Bob and Bob gets three
coins from Alice so you know in an
honest execution nobody loses
money the money exchanges you know
Alice's coins are not with Bob but Bob's
coins are not with Alice so so this is
good but but let's see what happens when
um when there are robots in this
protocol right that that was the whole
point of uh of having coins in this mix
so let's look at what what happens uh if
there's an abort and we want what we
want to do is like we want to penalize
aborts after every move so let's look at
like a sample scenario where uh uh where
let's say the first two messages happen
and then now Alice for some reason she
wants to maybe she's not winning the
game she just wants to stop the protocol
there so she does not want to send uh
the message M3 she just wants to stop
the protocol so once she does that then
we can see that uh these these
transactions are going to be refunded
back right so what in effect what has
happened is Alice gets gets two coins
whereas Bob gets four right so so they
started with three each but then now Bob
gets four of the six coins and Alice
gets two so in some sense basically Bob
gets compensated with Alice's money
right so this is how you would design a
a multiple move multiple move exchange
here so you basically penalize uh every
abort so this is I just showed you an
example of where an AB happens at at the
third stage with you can you can
generalize this to every any
stage so so now we have taken care of
the multiple Mo exchanges so let's look
at uh the other problem which is
basically like who deals the cuts and
the problem here is you cannot just let
any party deal the cuts but uh let's
just do this thought experiment with the
angel right so if you had an angel then
well the angel would deal the C then you
do some betting then the angel reveals
more cards you do some more betting you
know reveal new cards according to the
you know poker games and then you do
more betting and so and so forth so
everything is great but this actually
sets things up because we already saw
that SEC computation implements Angel so
you can just like get rid of the Angel
and then use protocol messages so you in
effect you have the secure computation
protocol uh which reveals player Cuts so
actually goes back to the classic you
know playing mental poker where they use
secure competition kind of some variant
of secure competition to implement this
Angel right but then we still have to
deal with this um uh secure competition
replaces the angel but it does not
guarantee fairness right so you players
can still abort uh after you know during
the secure competition or right after
the secure competition Pro you know
right after Bob gets his cards and he
doesn't like them he can abort or he can
like at the very end when he knows
for sure that he's not going to win he
can aboard right so SEC competition does
not give anything let's not do anything
about that but then uh we saw this
multiple Mo exchanges right and we are
going to apply that contract on top of
this on top of this game so so what we
are basically going to do uh is
basically uh looking at this this
protocol is having like two types of
moves basically one is like secure
computation moves these are uh these are
the red messages and one is like betting
moves where where you just ask the
players to sign their bets right and
then both both have like some conditions
checking the validity of these messages
so you have you have uh you have the
these the SEC competition protocol as
well as the best the bests have to be
made according to the poker rules so you
still have some so these moves specify
some conditions on on how the entire
protocol should move and then you have
you have this like multiple Mo exchanges
on top of these on top of these
conditions and then you can you can
ensure that you you play a game of poker
if someone aborts then uh the honest
party still gets
compensated right so so this takes so so
what we have seen so far is that either
the honest party gets gets compensated
or the poker game is completed uh until
its very end right and what we need to
do is basically adding the pay to the
winner the winner needs to get the money
right so you you you play you play the
game you you exchange some moves at the
end of the game there is some winner and
then the winner should get should get
the moves and and the way you do it is
basically uh have some conditions on the
messages which says that you know the
blue condition uh equals one on on the
entire transcript of the protocol it's
one if only if Alice wins and and the
red condition checks Bob wins and then
you just add like a couple of
transactions at the at the beginning
then you're good so so you do all oops
so you do all you play the game until
here at this point you are ensured that
either either the honest party gets
compensated or the poker game is
completed and then after that the winner
can take like one Bitcoin so here I'm
assuming that the payout is one
Bitcoin right so what we have uh at the
end of the day is basically a poker game
where you don't have to trust any third
party there's no online casino or
dealers that you trust you just use a
secure competition
protocol uh but it also guarantees it
also takes care of the fairness issues
you have like guaranteed payout to the
honest party or compensation and in the
and in the poker game you can set you
can set the compensation equal to the
maximum value of the pay so you have a
fully self enforcing contract either the
winner wins the part or it gets a
compensation which which equals the part
so so it's good either
way winner so those dep
on yes so the condition depends on on
the entire transcript actually each of
these messages like fe2 depends on both
uh the first two messages FM depends on
the first M messages and the last
winning condition depends on all M
messages yeah
so the condition is still checking like
a lot of information it's checking the
entire that happens just at the end of
theame yeah so the deposits uh so people
put up their deposits up front because
they know these conditions ahead of time
right and then when when you are
claiming it you can claim it you can
claim it only if you win so so out of
the top two only one of them is going to
get claimed the other one will get
refunded right so so that's how the
winner gets gets gets the payout so yeah
so so this what you can do yeah does the
amount of money that each player depits
as insurance depend on the amount of PS
that they might do is there a pattern
there yeah there is there is a pattern
so here here the the compensation equals
1 Bitcoin the payout is also one
Bitcoin so it depends on you you can
vary these things uh it's it's
relatively flexible but but ideally what
you want is uh if someone cheats then
the other one should get the money as if
he won the game right so that's what you
want so you can you can just set the two
equal and there you go so you get like a
pretty good uh self enforcing poker
contract so so the idea that we saw with
poker you know about like using a secure
computation protocol and then putting
like a multiple move uh contract on top
of it it's fairly General you can you
know you don't have to do the secure
competition for just the game of poker
you could do the secure competition
protocol for any function f right so
what you actually get is basically
starting with this claim or refund
transactions and use secure computation
you you get like smart contracts and you
can make them privacy preserving you
know using secure computation we saw
before right so so far I've shown you
this privacy preserving aspect let me
let me talk about like scalability
okay so we already saw something about
like scalability between uh you know how
how we actually reduce this information
to information exchange to just a key to
key exchange so this information could
be several megabytes within the key is
just like 128 bits right and here I uh I
want to make the this distinction
between uh the onchain complexity and
the offchain complexity so what I mean
by offchain complexity basically the
secure computation part something that's
that's done locally does not go on the
blockchain at all it's just done locally
between the two parties nobody else has
to see it right so that is offchain and
uh for the next few slides we will
assume that this is cheap this is this
is local competition right nobody else
the the Bitcoin network does not need to
see the the escrow does not need to see
they don't need to participate on it so
this is we'll call it cheap for for the
time being and this exchange is what
goes on the blockchain and this this is
what we call as the onchain complex here
you probably have to pay a transaction
fee for every claim or refund
transaction and the the entire network
may may have to verify if it's going on
the blockchain right so what we want to
minimize is basically we want to
minimize onchain complexity and we don't
so much care about offchain complex at
least for the next few slides
okay and what we saw before was
basically kind of like making the
onchain complex independent of the size
of the information you just you just
exchange case you don't you don't care
about like how big the information is uh
that is all handled inside the secure
competition
part so this is scalability with respect
to the size of the information let's
look at scalability with respect to like
other dimensions so so far we have seen
only like uh two party exchanges let's
look at like a multi-party exchange
where where a set of end parties they
want to perform an nway
exchange okay and then the problem
becomes like much worse here because all
of them might collude against one
party right so so so in this case when
all of them C against one what what what
you need to kind of ensur that if
anybody aborts then you kind of need to
compensate everybody because you don't
know who is the honest party right so if
someone aborts then you want to
compensate everybody and what we saw
until now is basically these claim or
refund transactions but these were just
two- party transactions right so they
were not multi-party there just between
Alice and Bob you know someone setting
up some condition and putting some money
and it was a two- party uh simple
transaction but this were only like two
parties and now we are in a multiparty
setting and and the question is well can
we implement this nway exchange where
you you want to be resistant to you know
all kinds of collusions against one
party can we can we implement this using
just claim or refund transactions these
are simple two-party exchanges can we do
nway exchanges from two- party exchanges
right and here my work shows that you
can actually do multiparty exchanges
using claim or refund transactions so
this is actually how the how the
transaction graph looks like know it
looks a bit weird because the arrows
going both ways from these parties I
just want to say that uh uh the
mechanism much more complex and each of
these arrows have like are checking for
different information the arrows also
carry like different amounts of money
just to make sure that uh you know if
all of them collude against against one
you still want to ensure that the honest
party gets compensated so so the
mechanism is more complicated but it can
be done just using your simple two-party
transactions so so we are boosting
simple two- party transactions to
complex multiparty transactions so
that's the way to think of
it so this is the multiparty case but
you could think of like a different
scalability dimension uh let's say
scalability with respect to like
multiple exchanges maybe maybe a set of
parties performed an exchange they like
it they want to perform one more
exchange they want to perform like a
million more
exchanges the problem with this is that
you need to make onchain transactions
for every exchange because the you know
for every time you make you make this
exchange uh the conditions are different
right the conditions depend on the
information that you're being that is
being exchanged in different
transactions you know even involving the
same parties different transa different
contracts are going to have like
exchanges of different information so
the conditions are going to change so so
so do you need like onchain transactions
for every exchange or can do like
something slightly clever can we can we
can we do like just make one set of
transactions on the blockchain and Som
of use it for multiple exchanges so what
I mean by this is you put uh one set of
transactions on the blockchain do
exchanges locally if the exchanges is
good great you go to the next exchange
do it locally if that is also good keep
going but somewhere down the line maybe
the 10,000 exchange something goes wrong
then you can always go and appeal to the
blockchain and get your compensation so
that is that is kind of what I want here
right so we make only one set of
transactions
uh even though the the conditions on the
transaction depend on the information
exchange we want to somehow bypass that
maybe some put some kind of like some
Universal condition up front and then
use uh make all these exchanges local
something goes bad then you go and take
your compensation that's what we want
and here my work shows that you can
actually do these uh exactly what I told
before so you can do an unbounded number
of exchanges using just a single set of
claimer refund transactions again here
uh secure competition is going to be
very important to set things up you know
in setting these Universal conditions up
front so that nobody can nobody can
cheat so uh let's look at like another
dimension of scalability so here I want
to look at in terms of yes in this case
do you want that you should know what
all part parties are going to
participate exactly exactly so it's the
same set of parties they're going to run
a secure computation up front they're
going to generate some kind of like
Master secret ke Master public ke to to
set these like claim or refund
transactions and then they they go ahead
and do but it's still like exchanges
between the same sort of parties so the
next slide we'll talk about exchanges
between multiple parties so so here we
are talking about like infrastructures
for contracts you know uh there are many
parties in the universe and maybe all of
them want to perform exchanges like
let's say Parise exchanges and ideally
what you want to do or what what happens
in today's world when when you know a
lot of people want to do exchanges they
don't even know whom they're going to
exchange with well you have like some
kind of a client server architecture
right so clients put up what they want
exchanged or what what what things
they're looking for and then the server
does the matchmaking you go search for
what information you want and then the
server gives you a listing and then you
choose to do the exchange right and then
there you can use our The three-party
Exchange uh you know three-party
exchange you you can use it here to
facilitate exchange between Alice and
Bob and use it you you use it with the
server but then you don't have to trust
the server in particular the server can
collude with Bob against Alice but still
you're fine Alice will be ensured that
either the exchange happens or she gets
some kind of
compensation right but this is still bad
in the sense that the total number of
transaction now grows quadratically with
the number of parties because if you
look in this diagram there is still an
arrow between Alice and Bob right so any
so if Alice wants to perform an exchange
with uh with uh with Carol then there
there has to be an arrow between like
Carol and Alice right for for any pair
of parties you'll need you'll need a
claim or refund transaction going
between them right so this is still bad
the total number of transactions going
to go quadratic in the number of parties
in the universe so can we do
better and here I want to take you back
to this like four party diagram that we
saw before so if you look in this
diagram like slightly closely then you
see that there is no Arrow between
Alison
BM right so in the in the in the general
multiparty case uh the number of
transactions actually linear so this in
particular means that not all pairs of
parties are are involved in claim or
refund transactions what this means is
that you can you can call uh Carol and
and Dave as as like uh as the server so
everybody
makes everybody makes transactions with
the server as as if they're playing in a
in a four-party game where where they
don't need to know because they're not
making because Alice is not making a
claim or ref transaction to Bob she does
not even need to know who Bob
is right and still you don't trust the
server because this is a four-party
mechanism which is resistant to
collusions of up to three parties so the
server can collude with Bob against
Alice and still you're fine Alice has
ensured uh a fair exchange the sense
that either the exchange happens or she
gets compensated right so what you have
is a client server architecture with
like linear number of onchain
transactions
yeah
dur uh yeah so just before the actual
exchange they have to perform uh some
secure competition involving the server
as well but uh the claim or refund
transaction itself you you don't need
you don't need an Plus on top of this
you can think of this as like using
using the scheme from before where you
can make a set of transactions and do
unbounded number of exchanges so you can
amortize at that level so you everybody
registers with the server make some
claim or refund transactions with the
server and then they amortize over like
multiple exchanges you involving
different parties and you still have
only like linear number of onchain
transactions uh among parties in the
universe as opposed to quadratic
quadratic you can easily do using the
results from before for linear you have
to you have to use this like more
slightly more complicated scheme so what
we have shown is basically you know
starting from this claim or and
transactions the simple transactions
two- party transactions but then using
secure computation you can boost them to
like smart contracts which are scalable
as well as privacy preserving so so this
is what I've I've showed you so far and
uh We've show we've discussed like
scalability issues with respect to
onchain complexity let's go and look a
little bit more into like the offchain
complexity which is basically secure
computation we were using secure
computation left right and Center in all
of in all of the schemes but how
practical is secure computation right is
secure computation something that can
run today or or is it not so here I want
to say that you know SEC competition is
is like a major area of research and
cryptography especially in the last
decade me like tons and tons of papers
uh improving uh the efficiency of secure
competition and uh in this regard I've
done work uh in improving the asmic
complexity in terms of like um you know
reducing the dependence on um on the on
the size of the function let's say uh
and also concrete efficiency where I
mean by Factor 5x Improvement Factor 10x
Improvement and stuff like that both in
the two- party as well as in the
multiparty setting I've also worked on
uh uh designing more efficient building
blocks for secure competition like
oblivious transfer or cryptographic
commitments and obviously the more
efficient your building blocks are the
more efficient your your secure
competion protocol is I also done some
work on uh studying the cryptographic
assumptions for uh for some of the
Practical uh secure competition
techniques like like free
exor uh so so what I want to say is you
know SEC competition is something that's
is definitely moving from Theory to
practice and for some of the
applications for example the poker
application you know the function is not
that large you know every game of poker
is going to be like maximum 15 rounds
and it's it's a very small it's a very
small function those things you know for
those things SEC Compu is definitely
practical if you're talking about like
real time secure computation that's
still that's still a bit out there and
we don't know still how to do it but for
for some very simple functions totally
it's totally
doable and actually secure competition
was my main area of research uh until I
started working in like smart contracts
and the reason why I started looking at
smart contct basically secure
computation you know gives gives you the
best possible privacy but does not give
you fairness you know it's uh it does
not prevent this cheating strategy just
and cannot prevent because there's an
impossibility result right but just
because there's an impossible result
doesn't mean this is not a cheating
strategy and you still have to do
something about it in the real world you
know this is a cheating strategy just
get the output and stop the computation
and I was looking at smart contracts in
in this way so maybe if if you have a
fairness problem then you want to
penalize the the cheating party and you
want to compensate the the honest party
and this is this somehow like a very
good relaxation for for getting F secure
computation but why stop just like
penalizing aborts you know secure
competition involves like a lot of
expensive cryptography to to to prevent
cheating you know they use zero
knowledge proofs or cotton Cho
mechanisms and and this all adds to the
cost of secure competition but maybe we
can do something better right why
penalize only AB maybe I can penalize
like General cheating so maybe the
adversary cheats in a in a specific way
then then he will have to pay some huge
penalty and actually we were able to
translate this idea and get like better
more efficient secure competition
product using this idea this I don't
know if you know about the Dual
execution protocol where uh where a bit
leaks and then um where one bit leaks
but then the the leak bit you can um uh
you can detect if the if the bit is
leaked and this this result basically
say so so one bit leakage is great uh
because you know if you're having a
large data and one bit is leaked it's
not a big deal but when you're doing
like multiple executions of that when
you're doing like billions of executions
you you basically leak the entire data
and what this is does is that uh uh we
still allow one bit leakage but then if
you if the leakage is detected then
we'll impose a huge penalty on on on the
on the cheating party so you can you can
try to cheat multiple times but then one
of the times you're going to pay end up
paying a huge penalty it's just not not
just caught but you also end up paying a
huge penalty and we still do it while
keeping like the Dual execution cost the
same in the optimistic setting so so
that is this result also inspired by the
infrastructures for smart contracts we
also looked at scalable infrastructures
for for secure competition itself where
you can imagine like a network uh where
some parties have done some
pre-processing and they have set up you
know performed some expensive
pre-processing uh and other part is that
they still haven't set up expensive
pre-processing so can they use the rest
of the network to to do something so
this you can think of like bgw for for T
greater than N2 like where where the
infrastructure is like some oblivious
transfer preprocessing so that kind of
result and this was again inspired by uh
by by the infrastructures question for
smart contracts
so uh yeah so so far i' I've talked
about like information to information
exchange information to money but let's
let's let's look at like other parts of
this diagram let's let's talk about like
computation to money exchange okay and
this is something that happens all the
time it's basically you know cloud
computing or Outsourcing right so the
client wants some computation to be
performed uh the cloud is performing the
computation in exchange for some money
right but let's consider a setting where
where either party could be malicious
maybe the client pays up front but then
the server doesn't compute at all or the
server computes first but then the
client never pays right so again you
have like some kind of uh you need an
atomic uh exchange of computation for
money it's like a chicken and egg
problem but we were solving chicken and
egg problems before with information
information exchange right uh and here
we actually have a result which shows
that you can you can make these
exchanges automic uh again we'll just
use the claim or refund transactions
that we saw before it involves like
using verifiable computation schemes and
also some secure competition to
bootstrap things and you can still do
this but uh this was still a setting
where you have a single client and a
single server what happens if if a
client wants to Outsource the
competition to a large Network and here
a question is actually motivated by by
Bitcoin itself if you think of Bitcoin
at some very kind of like at a deep
level there is a uh there is an exchange
of computation for money happening so
Bitcoin mining they're doing all these
like proofs of work there's a lot of
computation in exchange they get some
rewards from the Bitcoin system right so
they do this Mining and then they get
some Bitcoin return so in some sense
that's a that's a swap of in computation
for money but this uh but this proof of
work on all the computations is being
done by the minus it's totally useless
outside Bitcoin it's actually like a
tremendous stress on on the environment
right it's a lot of competition energy
doing nothing outside Bitcoin and it
would be great if you can you know match
this up with this so so a client wants
to Outsource some useful competition
maybe give it to the miners and maybe
also uh you know have have have the
miners perform useful competition and at
the same time maintain a currency system
can we do this right so here it needs
like uh a deeper understanding of of how
consensus mechanism in Bitcoin actually
works and how how crucial is Bitcoin
mining to this process uh so it's
actually a new security model for uh for
consensus itself Bitcoin itself provides
a new new security model and in this
area I've have done some work in uh in
designing like broadcast protocols and
new security models like models where uh
you know the public infrastructure could
be comp compromised and you still need
uh uh you still need uh to solve Bine
agreement but this is like a slight this
is a very different problem it's a
dynamic setting parties are coming in
and going out not everybody's connected
to everybody else so it's a it's a much
harder setting but but if you can
combine these two things that that would
be like that would be a dream goal right
so moving on to like more General
contracts contracts which involve all of
them so we actually saw this example of
monthly installments where like a key
unlocks a car if if the monthly
installment is paid in all the protocols
that I've showed you before parties put
a security deposit up front before they
start the protocol but in this monthly
installment setting I mean the whole
point of using monthly installment is
that they don't have the security
deposit up front right so this is like a
a very different problem right and uh
also you can think of like simple
interest where the money keeps growing
over
time or you can go on like more like
Wall Street stuff like stocks bonds
options like all kinds of like complex
financial instruments and the protocols
that I showed you do not do not really
solve this and we need like new ideas
here so this is this is something that I
consider like very exciting work and
also in the other direction uh if you
look at like um exchanges that happen
today in the world you know think about
like Amazon you're you're getting like
physical objects for money and so there
exchange of objects and money sometimes
like objects for objects like on eBay
and here we want to like uh you know how
do you how do you even like use the
ideas that I showed you before like how
do you how do you construct this like
condition fee what is an authentic
object so there's been some work on like
Compu on objects itself so I don't know
if you might have heard about this uh
more famous work by boas Barak on
Computing about on like nuclear warhead
missiles just to make sure that
everybody is uh diffusing the correct
nuclear warhead so there's been some
work but there's a lot more lot more to
be done and also how do you capture
value of of objects you know if you want
to set up like a security deposit or a
penalty you you need to set up that
value depending on the value of the
object or or even like value of
information how do you capture value of
information what is the value of an
information is time dependent uh and
also sometimes uh just just putting like
some value on the information itself
might leak some information about about
the secret information so there are all
kinds of like more more complex stuff
here right but this is something that I
want to do I want to explore in the
future so uh that's it thank
you sorry for going over
time so talk about multi exchanges right
can you do the general contracts with
multi party like could you do the poker
contract yeah so again and now the
message is see I I didn't show all those
like multiple move contract becomes like
much more complex in the multiparty
setting especially when you have to be
resistant with collusions uh but the
secure multiparty computation protocol
still exists it doesn't give you
fairness but it still exists right
against like collusions of up to n minus
one out of end parties so it's still
being messages according to the secure
competition protocols being exchanged
there are bets being exchanged and then
you can apply a multiparty contract
which I do not sure but you can apply a
multiparty contract on that and you can
still run this protocol in a way such
that uh you know either the pro the
protocol completes the poker game is
fully executed or if someone aborts in
the middle could just be one party
aborting in the middle then everybody
else gets
compensated but doesn't poker have like
a condition that you shouldn't show your
yeah show your cards in what and what's
it depends right sometimes when you're
winning if if you're playing if you and
I are playing and I'm malicious and I
have four people at the table and you
only one
person yeah so that is like
uh yeah so that is they play honestly I
think right so it depends so if uh so
the issue that you're hinting at is
basically collusions right so there are
five parties but four parties are
actually have are communicating out of
band and then they basically share all
their cards and then it's it's really
unreasonable uh for for the honest party
uh so so secular competition in general
like does not solve the collusion
problem at that level where out of band
communication is when you start with an
input but if you have like additional
information then SEC competition does
not guarantee anything uh but with the
two-party pocal you know you don't have
to worry about collusion because there
are only two parties you know what do
what does out of band communication even
mean uh in the multiparty case and when
you want to design something which is
collusion resistant you need uh you need
more uh you need other kinds of ideas
here yeah there's a class of contracts
that have this problem right yeah so out
of band out of band communication so so
you can use uh so that that's that's
definitely an open question and you can
use like some of the ideas which are
showed like you can have uh so so you
can have like um uh uh a central server
uh but this is not like your uh regular
online casino which deals the Cs Etc is
there only for like facilitating The
Exchange but it also can keep track of
uh players transcripts from like
different games and then maybe it can
you know you'll need like more
cryptographic magic stuff for for for
the server to perform like some kind of
Statistics uh on on the poker gam so far
which is basically what your online
casino also does in order to to prevent
collusions right they keep track of
who's playing at what times who is
playing with like other pairs of parties
and whether they're cheating is some
kind of uh some kind of Statistics
algorithm that they run in the
background and uh you could go to such a
model if you use the you know the client
server infrastructure that I that I
showed you before where the server it's
there in the exchange just to just to
facilitate it's not going to deal the C
is not going to do anything it's just
going to make sure that uh the the game
of poker is played properly but at the
same time it also has access to the
transcripts at some level you still need
more more cryptographic like homomorphic
encryption type style stuff to to
perform under the encrypt without
without the server learning what the
cards are but yeah that's that's
definitely something which is open you
know it's a great question great
research question for the future yeah
thanks so you talk very briefly about uh
ethereum right yeah it is a new kind of
digital currency and I think they
provide uh facility for doing smart
contracts yeah so they don't have any
privacy preserving so yeah yeah so the
there um it's a very interesting
comparison between like ethereum and and
the stuff that I showed you here so in
ethereum you program your smart
contracts like the full contract you
just program and put it on the
blockchain right and uh when you need to
enforce this contract everybody in the
network has to has to enforce this
contract right so all the computations
uh so it does not it does not operate at
the claim or refund transactions level
it operates at a much more macro level
where everybody so the burden on the
blockchain is huge you put like all so
ethereum provides like a programming
language for for scripting any kind of
contract so you you put your program up
in the in the blockchain and when
someone needs to like um uh you know
change the state of the contract then
they post a message to the blockchain
and everybody all the miners are going
to upgrade the state of the contract so
so in effect uh the bad part is
basically uh is that like everybody on
the network needs to do the the contract
work so it's not a contract between two
people it's a contract between two
people but the contract is going on the
blockchain as a result everybody is
performing the
computation so this is the scalability
issue right so again when when they when
when you need to check whether the
information matches the condition the
minors are doing this work right and
there we want to like reduce this
dependence on the information you know
we just want to check a key against a
hash as opposed to like a big chunk of
information with a condition right so e
in ethereum like everything is is very
complicated and it's at the level of
like huge pieces of information
interacting with each other but ethereum
no privacy yeah plus there is no privacy
you can you can add some cryptography to
get some privacy and maybe use zero
knowledge proofs as snugs but still you
know you don't get the great scalability
issues the great scalability benefits
that you get by by using some offchain
competition so so the key idea that that
I showed you here is using secure
competition as an offchain do most of
the hard heavy lifting off the chain do
you use only like the key to exchanges
on the chain or something like much
simpler so that you you get like better
scalability also you know once you start
working with like claim or ref
transactions you can also amortize
across different exchanges such things
are not possible in uh uh in ethereum if
you just hardcode your entire contract
but the cool thing about what I said
here is basically you can Implement
claim or ref transactions in ethereum
and still have all the protocols that I
showed you here right so ethereum Pro
supports all kinds of contract but also
supports claim or refund transaction
just use claim or refund transactions
use the protocols that I showed you here
that's like one answer to the scale bu
issues that ethereum will probably face
in the future
yeah
cool thank
you thanks